I wrote it I said
[Music]
my world was turned upside down when my
very first boyfriend ever Sainik changed
his relationship status from in a
relationship to it's complicated without
even telling me I didn't call him about
it I sent him a five-page email that was
full of expletives all caps and rage
humiliated as if what he had done was
sent like a press release to every major
news outlet in the country and I just a
lot to know it was horrible I reacted
totally inappropriately and I kept
sending emails he never responded I'd
send another one because you know you
keep thinking of things to say and then
at the end of it it was just totally
humiliating and I said um we'll talk
later I have a board meeting tonight
which was technically true I was at AB
kind of place and had a board meeting
but I was just taking notes there and we
never talked again I ended the
relationship because he changed it so
pro-tips
don't use all caps ever when sending
emails because it just makes you look
crazy and unhinged just people
you